I think he's absolutely correct about
the World Health Organization I think if
you if you took President Xi of shot
China turned him upside down and shook
him the World Health Organization would
fall out of his pocket and that's not
acceptable Louisiana Senator John
Kennedy with his unique style there
echoing the president criticizing the
World Health Organization's handling of
the Cova 19 outbreak as the White House
threatens to cut off funding to the
agency let's bring in Arkansas Senator
Tom cotton a member of the intel banking
and Armed Services Committee good
morning senator
good morning yet I noted that your
colleague senator cannon he has a pretty
unique style and a manner of speaking
but bottom line I see your smile there
is the World Health Organization an
apologist for China
unfortunately the World Health
Organization is in the pocket of China
ad and specifically dr. Ted Rose he was
a cabinet minister in Ethiopia when
China was investing deeply there and
bribing cabinet officials he has a well
known and frankly well deserved
reputation for corruption that's gone
from Ethiopia now to the w-h-o that's
why the president is right that we need
to conditioned future funding of the
w-h-o on reforms going forward
transparency about the past on the
replacement of the leadership at the
w-h-o and the admission of Taiwan at
least as an observer to the w-h-o if we
can't do that then we're gonna have to
establish our own organization and
invite members of the civilized world to
join us using American standards of
transparency and accountability
well senator you just mentioned the
director of the World Health
Organization he fired back yesterday he
had a warning for the President and
maybe for you as well take a listen if
you don't want many more body bugs then
you refrain from politicizing it my
short messages please quarantine
politicizing kovat so he said you keep
this up there's going to be more body
bags is there a point there regardless
of the back-and-forth that cutting off
funding for a World Health Organization
that has made mistakes clearly but it's
trying to prevent
future pandemics that it could backfire
on us and I'm disgusted by that kind of
threat from some two-bit third-rate
international bureaucrat that's why dr.
Ted rush needs to be fired frankly he
needs to be investigated so we can find
out just how deeply in China's pocket he
is going back to January as pointing out
that the World Health Organization was
more interested in politically correct
appeasement of China calling the virus
something besides what it should be
called which is the China virus of the
Wuhan coronavirus than it was trying to
get to the truth so for instance it
accepted China's false ludicrously false
claims that there was no human human
contact in the early days of this virus
it refused to respond to some of the
learnings that we had from Taiwan
because Taiwan is not viewed by Beijing
as a country those are the kinds of
things that have to change at the World
Health Organization and dr. Ted Joyce's
two-bit accusations and threats are not
going to change those facts all right
you certainly had a chance to respond
there let's bring it back home with
what's happening with very hard-hit
families in your state and states all
around the country right now we've seen
these unemployment claims going up you
and others on the hill have been trying
to do a lot with the stimulus there have
been questions about whether the small
business loans are really getting to the
people who need it senator McConnell's
gonna talk on that next hour in the
meantime you and Doug Jones Democratic
colleague are saying you got to get the
money faster as well to individuals you
said we encouraged the Treasury
Department to offer a targeted group of
Americans the option of receiving their
direct assistant payment on direct
express debit cards which you use to
other for other federal benefits like
Social Security and Veterans Affairs
benefits talk about the focus on this
and is there a concern that the money is
just simply not getting the people who
need it quickly enough so the small
business loan ads there's obviously been
some bureaucratic snafu we're working
out the kinks every single day my team
and I have been on the phone almost
constantly with bankers in Arkansas and
the small business administration and
the Department of the Treasury I know a
lot of senators have been doing that as
well for the individual payments many
people will be getting those direct
deposits starting next week through the
bank account information at the IRS but
there are obviously millions a
Americans who don't have direct deposit
setup they may not even have bank
accounts rather than send them paper
checks which are susceptible to fraud
and require you to get out of your house
and go to the bank cash the cheque we
want the Treasury to explore the
possibility of electronic debit cards
the kind of things we already used the
VA or the Social Security Administration
which will make it easier for some of
those folks who don't have bank accounts
who are in communities that are
underserved by financial institutions to
get this money they need to buy the
groceries or pay the bills it's just one
possibility that we think Treasury
should explore to make sure that
distressed workers and their families
are getting the relief they need in a
timely fashion that's an important
initiative on the individual side as you
noted there's also the small business
side a lot of folks really hard hit
Senator McConnell expected to speak as
early as the next hour we'll go there
live if he does about this potential
expansion of two hundred and fifty
billion dollars more in small business
loans senator cotton you got a lot on
your plate appreciate you coming in
today thank you